Here's a book I read recently .... Very
interesting, about how to be relaxed.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I want to talk about
how I learned German.
Uh, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe like on a
bell on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
I do appreciate it.
So my major effort into learning
German took place in 1987.
And I'm going to go through that with you.
But I did have prior exposure to German.
Uh, my parents were from Czechoslovakia.
They spoke German at home, although they
spoke English with my brother and with me.
So I hadn heard German,
but I couldn't speak it.
Then I worked on a German ship for
two weeks hitchhiking over to Europe.
Uh, I hitchhiked around in Germany.
I even worked for two weeks on
a construction site in Vienna.
So I had some use of German,
but it was very rudimentary.
So in 1987, I was between jobs.
I had a month off between jobs and I said,
you know, I really want to learn German.
And I had, you know, prior to getting
on that German boat, I'd looked
at a grammar book ..., whatever.
And it's always, it struck me that it was
just impossible to remember those things.
1987, long before I had heard of
Stephen Krashen or input or LingQ.
Um, I said, I need to read, I need to
read to get a sense of this language.
I need to get the language in me.
So let me show you what I did.
First of all, I went to the second-hand
bookstores here in Vancouver.
I don't know what got into me, but I
said, let's see what, what is there.
So I found this book, which is pretty old.
It's a university of Southern California.
1959 it was published.
And if you look at the book it's,
it's got sort of text and a, it's
got a vocabulary, you know, along
the margin, which is really good.
You don't have to flip back for it.
Now, of course, it's not going to
get all the words that you don't
know, but quite a few of them.
And as often happens, some of the words
they explain for you, you already know.
And you'll see that it's a secondhand book
because this is not my writing in here.
It's full of at least one other
person, perhaps more look at this,
you know, scribbling, all kinds of
stuff, uh, you know, in the text.
But, uh, it look at this one.
I mean, there's some person undertook
to translate the whole thing, which...
how you can even read the
little chicken scratch, but at
any rate, so I read through.
So, but that's not the only book I found.
I found this other book called ... and
here it's a little more organized
and they have a word list behind
every chapter and I found, you know,
so it's again, the same idea:
always text with word lists.
If you can see that.
Alright.
Not tremendously interesting,
perhaps, but I was motivated.
Oh, here's another one that I did.
... so here again, and I love history and
so I love this book, but this didn't
have the, um, you know, the glossary.
So it was more difficult to
read and I just let whatever
words I didn't know fly by.
Uh, here's another one that I
got ... and here again, uh, you know,
lots of, um, vocabulary and texts.
And of course I avoid any, any sort
of exercises or things of that nature.
But at any rate, these are the things
that I plowed through in that month.
And I got a lot of them, you know?
... and I mean, these books are
probably largely out of print
...
So more of the same, more of the same.
And I don't know if you can
see here, but just an endless,
you know ... more of the same.
Now this one I think is my
highlighting, uh, ... Whatever.
Okay.
Lots.
Now, at some point I changed like,
okay...and there's literature and there's
...  When I was in Tyrol, I got interested.
Uh, what do we got here?
...again with, with the
exercises and whatnot.
I mean, no.
And just listen and learn.
Now, I don't know whether this matched,
but at some point I found a cassette
tape series, which was a series of
interviews, uh, from, uh, German
radio interviews with normal people.
That was the best.
I listened to it over and over again.
If I get a hold of audio material
where I find it interesting,
and I find it pleasing to listen
to it's almost like music.
And even if I don't fully understand
it, I just listen and listen to that.
So, but I got lots of
books ... advanced German course.
I don't know what I did with that.
I mean, it just goes on and on.
And of course ...you got to read
the, because for something like
this, I also get the audio book.
So I won't go through all of these books.
I even got books on, uh, what else we got?
You know, books on ... which
is of interest to me.
And of course I was in the lumber
business and building was, you know, very
important to me so I read that in German.
Uh, what else did we do here?
Here's a book I read recently ... very
interesting, about how to be
relaxed, sort of a combination
of Zen and, uh, in the stoic
philosophy, how to relax in your life.
Um, you know, literature.
I also got some, I, here we are.
Yeah.
I got some, uh, some self-help books,
you know, how to become more efficient.
Um, this, uh, Leitner who sort of
designed a prototype of the, uh, spaced
repetition system, um, books on history.
This is an excellent book.
. I mean, it goes on and on.
Uh, and these books are kind of good.
...where you can learn vocabulary in a
new language, relating it back to German.
And so you're kind of picking
up vocabulary in both.
So, I mean, that's just a
quick sort of stab at that.
I wanted to demonstrate that, you know,
long before input and compelling input
was, was popular it had, it was always
obvious to me that that's how you learn.
And that's what I did for Chinese.
That's what I did for Japanese.
And I could go through all
my Chinese books, my Japanese
books, uh, I read and I listened.
In fact, behind me, here are CDs,
audio CDs, and lots for German, for
Swedish, for, you know, Italian,
Spanish, Czech, you name it.
And I could show you, you
know, the books for those.
And I may do that if there's interest.
The thing is now the world has changed.
And so now you can find content of
interest, you can find audio material
for download that you don't have to...
I used to have to go to Germany
and find CDs to listen to an audio.
You can find the audio material online.
Uh, if the material is older, like
Gerta, you can import the, uh, the
text into LingQ and listen to the audio
and learn, you know, go do the sort
of traditional literature that way.
If it's modern books, you
may have to buy the book.
And unfortunately, very often they
prevent you uh, you know, downloading the
text or downloading the audio, even if
you've paid for it, which is unfortunate.
Uh, but the world has changed.
So I, I perhaps should show you what I
now do on LingQ, uh, which is where I now
spend my time learning Persian and Arabic,
and I've learned other languages there.
I haven't really done that much
in German, but I have done some.
So let me just show you the sort of my
level of activity on LingQ for German.
So let's have a look here at
the, um, German page at LingQ.
And you can see that there's a lot of
different content available to study.
Here are some of the things that
I have looked at in my sort of
study shelf, nothing very recently.
Some of the trending things.
What's new, mini stories.
There's just a tremendous
variety of content.
So I don't have to go looking for it,
but I haven't done much on LingQ when
it comes to, um, you know, in German.
So if I click on my picture
here and I go to my profile,
then I will see what I've done.
So last seven days, nothing.
However, if I go to all the time, We can
get a sense of the level of my activity.
So here's the growth of my known
words, which on LingQ is 28,000 some.
So it's not like I haven't done much on
LingQ, I have done, but more in the past.
Typically 2009 seemed to be a
pretty active period for me.
Uh, if I look at, um, you know, uh,
LingQs created again, I was very
active for some reason in 2016.
Uh, if I look at listening hours,
this is not a good indicator because
I don't necessarily listen on LingQ.
I Might be listening elsewhere as well.
Uh, if I go to, um, you know,
uh, learned LingQs, these are the
words that I have moved to known.
Not very many.
So typically, um, I've been doing a lot
of listening and reading, uh, but I don't
necessarily move words to known on LingQ.
So in terms  of my LingQs created,
I've got a total of 11,000 words
that I have looked up, but the
known words total is like 28,000.
What that means is that there are
a lot of words that I simply didn't
bother looking up cause I knew them.
And so LingQ keeps track of that and
tells me that I know 28,000 words.
Anyway, that's just very briefly on
the subject of what I did on LingQ, but
this all comes well after my greatest
period of activity in learning German.
I wanted to show you what I
have done to improve my German.
My German is still not as
good as I would like it to be.
Uh, I make mistakes and I
was probably better before.
Uh, I have spoken German
here with, with people.
I'm a bit sort of shy about my German,
but if I have to speak up speak, I
would like to be better as is the
case with many of my languages.
But on the other hand, I brought my
German from a very rudimentary level
up to a level where I can understand,
I can read, I can read books for
pleasurem, I can speak to people.
And with a little bit of effort, I can
bring it back to where it was before
and improve it beyond that level.
And that's kind of the level that I like
to get my languages to call it sort of
a, a slightly, you know, dormant B2.
And once you're there, you don't lose
that much, even if you don't use the
language or read in the language.
And of course, I like to have
my languages, you know, parked
at that dormant B2 level so
that I can learn new languages.
And then when the opportunity or the
need arises, go back and recover those
languages that I have studied before.
So I hope that was of interest to you.
And I will leave you with a couple
of interviews that I've had in German
so that you can criticize my German.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.